you'd might know my guess best as the
Spoony one at the Spoony experiment.com
he is best known for reviewing
videogames be movies and just about
anything in geek culture he has also
starred and the unbelievably well
financed online films kickassia suburban
nights and tabouli flea and has allowed
me as director to abuse and more than
once on every single one of them please
welcome the incredibly awesome Noah ed
Weiler how are you sir I'm doing great
doing great thank you for bringing me
out here and thank you for abusing me in
many of your films I've been knocked out
twice on set in your films and I've
enjoyed every single second trust me
with the pleasure was all so okay we'll
just go right into the elf in the room
like what people want to hear about it
what's to talk about
um years ago there was a splitting of
the ways between you and I they caused a
lot of controversy and a lot of talk
people going on Twitter and speaking
about all sorts of things so I figure it
may sense up right here right now to
talk about it why the hell did you like
last action here because that film is a
piece I shit you know I called you out
on this a long time ago and to this day
I do not understand why you don't get
the fact that it's an intentional
lambasting of Arnold Schwarzenegger his
own career it is but it's not a good one
it took courage of him to do that and
the thing is it still holds up today
more so than it did last time having
dogs stack on top of each other like
awareness or to make a movie with that
what will get had a happy face in his
eyeball that was even better because
Charles dance not only delivered one of
the best performances of his career it
actually really in last action hero yes
by the way how dare you impugn Charles
dance in any one of his performances
because he still stands today as one of
the
actors working ever it's like making fun
of Tim Curry in any one of his perform
okay Tim Kurt that's kind of different
that you can't bet even when Tim curries
off when he's amazed this is what I'm
talking about you can't make fun of
Charles dance ever like until I see him
in drag then maybe over but in terms
dance yes cuz don't curry did it and was
still not credible but incredibly
entertaining well give it time but it'll
happen it'll probably happen but still I
mean it is remarkable that
Schwarzenegger even back then was
willing could you imagine any actor
today be willing to just essentially
destroy their own career on film like
that it's amazing but well anyway I
think we abuse this joke long enough ah
you just like it going with you guys
this is serious serious um okay but
speaking of reviewing how did you get
into uh this train wasn't something you
always want to do or did you fall into
this isn't always the way it's by
accident uh it's you you never want to
set out into wanting to get into sports
or entertainment um I I started doing
this mainly to this make my friends
laugh I wanted to start out doing a
Mystery Science Theater fan video you
know because I love mr. Science Theater
3000 and so I started off building
robots which sucks because I've no idea
how to build robots so I had my friends
do it for me no I I hope ah so I built
one robot and then I asked my friends
hey you guys want to watch some really
crappy movies with me several times and
then sit in my insanely hot garage in
front of a screen and then film the live
as we watch the movie again did you do
like the green screen the whole thing
like a really crappy screen yeah and
they were like no these flat out said
like no I'm like well crap because now I
had this robot and I had a camera I
bought a camera which was like three
hundred dollars which is luck money I
should check with him before you went
out yeah yeah and built a robot and all
that but so so now I had this camera in
this
but and this big interest in bad movies
and I had nothing to do it so I started
doing like movie commentaries like like
riff track before rough tracks was done
really bad ones too but I was like now I
wanted to do something so I just decided
to do a review of like by you Billy like
a really bad Nintendo game I knew that
james rolfe was doing like a video game
but I mind was much less structured you
know I think mine was unstructured but
the reception I feel like the game yeah
and it's like bidding yeah so I did a
couple and nobody was watching him I
posted them on a message board I was
working on and then I did Final Fantasy
8 and then all of a sudden I pissed
people off because nobody had dared kick
Final Fantasy 8 before that was like
sacred cow anything Final Fantasy was
sacred so all of a sudden viewership
skyrocketed because I started getting
hate mail because again sacred cow
people I was getting motive the worst
kind of hate mail death threats I don't
know nobody was doing it seriously but
you know the kind of internet vitriol
where it's like there's the only
language people speak on the Internet is
hyperbole so that like one of my
favorite hate mails was one of the first
hate mails I got was I hope you die
getting hit by a truck full of cancer
best imagery ever that is creative so uh
I just thought that cancer can be like
physical and put on a truck it is what
I'm into you I doubt if it was driving
but like so my all sudden my YouTube
viewer ship was just at the time most
amazing so I think it was kind of the
Howard Stern effect where like people
were watching and getting furious and
then showing their friends yeah see what
this prick is staying about Final
Fantasy became the Fox News of YouTube
oh yeah so I was essentially kind of
trolling and without meaning to I was
serious I really hated this game but I
was like as soon as I saw the the the
hits I was like I got about this game so
again I wasn't doing it for the hits I
was doing it because it was kind of
amusing me and I'm using a lot of people
so again I I started doing that and it
kept going and my viewership gets and
people kept watching because maybe they
didn't
they didn't like what I was saying but
they really wanted to hear more of what
I had to say and so from there it just
kind of kept going and eventually people
started to you know they realized I
think I was kind of a fun guy and that
we're really starting to kick off with
what I discovered into red-brown movies
for myself you know you're hunter from
the future was really I think we're kind
of locked in where's you know this is a
job you know this is I can discover bad
movies and show people the bad movies
and games that I that I for my childhood
he's still the best gap in America I
don't know what they're doing these new
ones but I mean it's not it's no Rick
Brown he's if he just wear a motorcycle
helmet with wings and a plastic shield
it's not what few negative reviews get
much more attention than positive
reviews I mean we focus on negative
reviews and we know it gets the view why
why is that you think people are that
always ask me like I have a reputation
now for Spoony hates everything and
stuff like that they ask me why don't
you review things you like why why don't
you review good things it's very hard to
be funny when you're being complimentary
you know this movie is so friggin good
it's awesome I love it so much
it's so good it's like better than
cheeseburgers how do you be funny about
really good things you know you can have
a lot of really awesome you know
metaphors and comparisons to really
crappy things you can be insulting and
and say what you want to do to things
that you hate you know you'd be violent
towards things you hate it's so hard to
be how do you you know it's you can't be
funny about things you like and kind of
an ironic way I've done this for April
Fool's videos but having how do you do
like funny sketches about things that
are awesome the closest I've ever found
is going so over the top yeah but you
like them but even then like you said
that can kind of get you only so much
mileage because that comes from the
person is clearly uh not in how much
they enjoyed it yeah which is why your
character the the bum is so funniest but
the thing is he's actually saying things
he likes about bad things you know
because it's it's in
version you know because the people who
watch it know that the things he's
reviewing are bad you're insulting it by
you're insulting it by sarcasm yeah and
not even realizing what he's saying yeah
it's actually bad about them so you can
do critical reviews of positive things
seriously but yeah I have done it like
when I reviewed like the first
Beastmaster movie I liked it the thing
is I was still nitpicking it you know uh
but at the end I was like this is still
great movie but it was kind of a guilty
pleasure type movie because even back
then the really good fantasy movies were
still really cheesy you know and you had
to acknowledge that I mean it's it is
difficult but I kind of done the same
thing with life you know it with my cook
and commando it's I love those movies
you know even the really horrible parts
you know I love them so much um and yeah
their way seems to be like yeah at least
have a passion for what do you love it
or hate it yeah uh you know I know we're
for it to be entertaining I did that
with Ferris Bueller's Day Off which I
love that movie but Ferris Bueller is
the devil I was Samantha Broderick is
the devil but I feel like you uh
questioned review of allotting is one of
the most popular series you've gone over
is the ultimate game hmm
uh why why do you have such a strong
connection with bags well they were
popular they're not it's not something
people were craving to have this be
reviewed and you've done pretty much all
but then they're extremely popular yeah
yeah it's mainly something I just grew
up with it was like um my older brother
was playing them it was really well it's
it's kind of a series of gaming as old
as the PC gaming itself because you know
they started off when operating systems
didn't have windows
you still had text prompts you know you
actually had to invoke your games by
typing in the title of the game and
stuff like that so my older brother had
you know ultimate three which was the
first one so it was kind of a bonding
experience between you know my brother
and I and so I kind of grew up with that
you know it's kind of the first gaming
series I really got grew up with and
it's it's makes me sound old but it's
it's a gaming series that the young uns
have not really been exposed to ever and
it's it's a shame because
it's one of those gaming series that
really has it's it's kind of one of
those classic sci-fi fantasy series that
that's kind of been forgotten but has a
really lasting like a legacy kind of
things so like it's kind of weird that
maybe in a sense like Star Trek the
original Star Trek it's Star Trek been
rebooted it's it's almost like the old
Star Trek gonna kind of fade out mail
Babylon 5 you don't really know about
1/5 anymore
so it's it's a nostalgia thing you know
it's like I don't want it to be forgot
because I grew up with that it's a great
series of games even when it was crap
you know it's like still grew up with
that and it's coming back
or at least it's there's an MMO coming
out and so I like to think that in some
small way I helped bring that piece of
history back or at least I helped
preserve it and it was it was kind of
funny is like one of the primary found
it one of the primary traumatic forming
memories of my childhood was the ultimen
ein thing where it's like one of the
biggest shocks to my pop culture system
was the what's a paladin thing
what's a paladin ah Oh God was where I
realized how badly they could screw
something up you know and it said but
the thing is I couldn't tell that story
without telling every story and this was
like a mission I realized that what I
had to do so was everything the whole
reason you want to do the games was to
build out the Ultima 9 I had to wow
that's that's a shot on game for one for
one gag for one but the thing is because
it wasn't that serious you know it
wasn't that serious
you're like in on what's a paladin you
know this for one if I just showed you
Ultima 9 you do like so what that's yeah
but the thing is you had to see all the
stuff that led up to it and then it
would be like if you win on that ride
for all nine games and then this guy
who'd been on like all these like 11
games up at that point there's nine and
then there's like a couple sites you're
like what then it'd be like Luke
Skywalker asking at the end of a front
of the
what's a Jedi place or what's the force
it wasn't like don't know this time only
public exactly no silly you would hit
the roof you would run out of the
theater screaming like who what clown
made this movie you know think that's
and besides that it wasn't like I was
wasting my time doing these reviews they
were all worth doing so I when I
realized I had to do I wanted to take
you on this journey it was it was a
journey with taking so it was awesome
I'd like doing that and so I'm glad
people found it I'm glad people like I
liked going on it with me and they
learned something and so I liked the
fact that people said told me that they
went back and discovered these games for
themselves well and they're definitely
you were talking about having an
influence or hopefully an influence and
maybe a coming back you actually got a
chance to meet the creator Deb altima he
wants his place Richard Garriott he went
on his turf to talk with him and how did
that happen and how surreal of an
experience was that I could not believe
it he contacts me he's making a game an
MMORPG called shroud of the avatar and
out of nowhere essentially he contacts
me saying I saw your videos and I was
thinking the next words out of evil
we're gonna be like and I will see you
in court but no he said I laughed my ass
off and I'm like and I will see you in
court and I don't laugh not even up and
he goes I'm like he says even when you
hated the games you hated them because
you love them so much that it hurt you
when they were when they were bad and he
says it made me understand because I
didn't understand at the time and why
they were bad I didn't even understand
like why when I did like what's a
palette and all that stuff I was just
trying to inform new gamers what a
paladin was I didn't even think at the
time this this is stupid I should just
have the the avatar ask what this is
because it's like a screen writing thing
you know this is something the character
should not I asked at this point so he's
like it helped
me you know it's so like it's something
I actually ask you know my developers my
my programmers now is to think about
this sort of thing so he says it
actually is helpful to me so he says you
know I you've actually helped kind of
bring this back and to kind of help
bring this back into consciousness you
know so he's like I want you to be part
of this so he actually made me part of
the Kickstarter goal for sure at the
avatar which I thought amazing and so
when they met the Kickstarter goal that
one of the things was a roast of himself
he was going to bring me down to Austin
to those to the studio to have we didn't
really know what the form of the roast
would take so I decided it would be like
our roast interview roast slash
interview so he took me down there and I
kind of did a I kind of did a sublet
hostile style interview it was a good
fun but like yeah it was really
remarkable because I didn't know what to
expect and he's he's such a nerd I know
right but like what I mean is he takes
me we did the interview and he takes me
down to Britannia Manor and he literally
has like a Renaissance Faire it's a real
Manor for it it has a castle he has the
biggest geocaching site in the world he
has like a tat like a lighthouse tower
and stuff like that you actually have to
go in like a quest to reach his
geocaching is it days they're like pits
of lava and kind of yes you have to go
on an all-day quest solving riddles to
get to the geocaching thing really you
have to like infiltrate his Manor and do
this there maybe minotaurs I don't know
but this is a guy who is either living
life incredibly wrong or incredibly
right yet to be doing that so he has
like a literal village around his manor
and so he takes us down there and he
points over there and he goes that's my
job sting list which is the first time
those words been uttered in like two
hundred years and I'm like ciao sting
list he goes oh yeah I let the
international jousting lead use my
jousting list every time they come
around here and I'm like there's a
jousting like oh yeah and
he's like that is a replica of the Globe
Theatre I go wow
she's like yeah I left it I left the
community theater dudes and I'm like
well that's good
and so yeah he takes me around an angry
joes with me he's helping me through the
camera
he's like Joe do you want to uh do you
want to fight with these exes and so he
hands him like I can't see him being
down for that at all I seem to be like
no I have a passiveness I do not believe
in violence on guests stay as far away
from this response so if ya angry he
hands angry Joe these cosplay foam axes
and Joe is like I'll take two and so
yeah and so I'm like Joe don't hit
Richard Garriott methods with the axes
if you heard Richard Garriott he's like
a millionaire he's been into space he
has an orbital laser and I'm like he's
like he's like come on Rudy and he like
he goes up on the stage of the Globe
Theater and he starts beating the shit
out of Richard Garriott with battle axes
and Richard Garriott is just laying into
him with a sword and another battle axe
and I'm sitting there wishing I had my
camera I'm trying to get my stuff ready
to shoot a sketch with him and I'm so
desperate to get my camera
but I sit there and I'm just watching
angry joe and Richard Garriott beating
the crap out of each other with battle
axes on the stage of the Globe Theater
and he looks so happy
and I'm like this is Richard Garriott a
millionaire he's been into space and he
just wants playmates
you know let's say he wants people to
play on his medieval village and he just
wants to make games you know and that's
I was like this is what it's this is
what the experience they're going to see
Richard Garriott Lord British you know
he's Lord British this is what it's like
going to see Richard Garriott the guy
who designed the Ultima games and I'm
like this is a gamer you know this is
what it's like to meet this guy after
all these years after all these years
that's what it's like so it I stopped
being scared of this guy because he's
beating the crap out of Anchorage over
the phone battle axe yep
I need that in such a surreal experience
every told him like just meeting you is
just did you ever tell him one
experience it was me oh yeah he
understood what it was like you know the
experience of growing up with this stuff
was like because he grew up with it too
you know he was basically like a
starting college student with it so he
learned just as much growing up with it
you know about programming in a business
essentially because the business kind of
screwed him over as much as anything you
know the story of the later Ultima games
the reason they were crap is essentially
its you know big business kind of bought
him out and made the games crap so you
know that we we all learned a lot about
life you know as as things progressed
and so yeah he under he understood what
he understood what it was like for a
gamer to meet him and and and so but
it's we it was kind of a unique
perspective for each of us you know for
the student to meet his master and the
master to finally see something that you
know what he had created out of a gamer
you know what I mean so which was kind
of this messed up manchild kind of I
love your work but I hate you one of my
favorite moments in any of your reviews
and one of the ultimate games you you
break character you can't break the for
the while you go and you grab all the
games and you go into great detail about
growing up with it and what it meant to
you and what it meant to your brother
and you really want the heck enzyme to
your childhood just talked about the
experience of doing this and it as a
reviewer I love anyone that can do
something really different and just
totally sort of break out a character in
a way that they haven't before that does
raise the question when is when is a
game just a game and when is it
something more when is any of media just
media and when is it something really
really important
I was nervous about doing that it to the
point where I I really considered
cutting it entirely because that's the
sort of thing you can only do once in my
opinion I really didn't want to break
character at the same time though I was
like this is really important to me
because what
you know uh that was redundant this help
now I wanted to carry up how how
important it was and that was the only
way was that they are okay we're stopped
we're stopping to be school like this
this is important you know you can't
screw something like this up you've come
this far you've come like eleven games
into this series can't do something like
this it's too important but you're like
but it's just a game yeah it's a game
get over it you know it's like to see
you screw up again but then this is
something like and this goes to
something like Star Wars you're like why
are you so mad about Star Wars the
prequels Jar Jar Binks it's a movie so
what movie sucks get over it and to a
degree you're right but it's a piece of
culture you know we grew up with this
it's important to us it's parts of our
childhood arena if it's not our
childhood it's a part of us so when you
screw that up
you screw parts of us up you know kind
of or you you screw up something
important to the country or you you've
made something wrong you know at least
to us you know so that you can argue
whether or not you know it's whether or
not it really is that important but it's
it can be offensive you know like it's
it's still important to us you know so
sometimes you have to just sometimes it
has a bigger importance than just being
a movie or just being a game to where it
becomes when you've come this far when
you have a series that big that
expansive you know like Star where that
Star Wars is probably a better example
because it became a phenomenon you know
it became part of the culture Star Trek
yeah you can't just do something to Star
Trek where Captain Kirk asks what's a
Klingon out of nowhere and they came
dangerously close to that with the
reboots where they couldn't fans could
have easily rebelled if they'd had done
something completely wrong in fact I'm
amazed they didn't when Spock yells
we were about ready to walk out of that
in fact had they done that I mean
handled even sure I almost did you know
you can see how it really could have
been like the most hated moment ever you
can see rage coming out of this you
could see like people burning this movie
in the streets had it had gone any worse
and you'd be like this is the movie and
he but no it's not just a movie this is
Star Trek this is pop this is common
parlance this is common usage you know
we use phrases like you know raising
your shields beam us up Scotty we use
stuff like this every day
you know so when you screw this up you
screw parts of culture up so you know
Ultima series
that's not common usage but that's part
of me you know so when I when I took
part of that and they screwed it up I
was like I grew up with this
you know I'm 33 years old oh my god you
screwed it up you know that was like no
no toss the game you know so like to me
it was important um obviously it was
important I did all these videos to lead
up to this and I was mad at the time I
was mad I'm still mad I went over to
Richard Garriott to tell him I'm mad you
know like why did you do this and he
told me why you know it was it was a
little bit beyond his control but he's
like I didn't know I didn't know any
better you know like I wrote this with
the best of intentions but I was stupid
and you told me why I was stupid I won't
do it again but yeah I mean that's the
things things kind of go past just being
a game sometimes um but yeah for the
most part what we do for like blood rain
or something like that when they adapt a
crappy video game is it worth really
getting mad over no yeah but sometimes
yeah if the ball were to take home hold
it start start never happen but yeah
yeah um if
Michael Pig gets hold of transformers it
kind of is worth getting angry over cuz
they deserve better don't it a little
bit yeah so they've been fighting to get
out of the hands of Michael Bay I'm Pro
for but they deserve better and it's is
worth getting angry over I think so
um but your mileage may vary it does but
that's that's why it's worth getting
angry over you have a very oh another
very well known passion for edges that
before Final Fantasy those really took
off and got people on talking about it
like you said death threats truckload of
cancer all that one to be very not that
many dumb but for that was it a similar
connection you had with uh Ultima or was
Final Fantasy just totally uh just a
totally different thing you know really
I think the Final Fantasy thing got
overblown to the point where I became
the Final Fantasy guy um it's fun uh
kind of seeing how far I can take that
one Final Fantasy 8 was really the first
one that I I just didn't like and
everyone else around me seemed to really
like it they just couldn't understand
why um and I just wanted to talk about
when I did the reviews but yeah it
really snowballed from there and I was
like this is amazing
and then Final Fantasy 10 came out and I
hated it because it had one of the most
annoying protagonists ever like screw
this and yeah those were the two I
really really hated and then thirteen
came out and I hated it you know but
nobody likes her team you know whatever
but yeah those are the first two games
and they were so wildly loved
I just wanted to destroy them but yeah
the other games are classics widely
regarded as classics and rightly so but
yeah the eight and ten are almost
universally beloved and those just
happened to be the ones that were like
really really recent then really in my
crosshairs at the time I didn't really
have so much but passion for them I
really wasn't even that protective of
the series actually not at all I'm not
like I love the series so much and I
hated the depth of which this year
the Sun I wish this plane final fancy
going like wow this sucks why do you
like it so much but people it was more
like a trolling reaction kind of at some
point where I was just like no this
sucks I'm gonna fight you on this so
yeah that wasn't less of a that was less
of a fanboy reaction on my part more of
like a no I'm gonna prove you wrong yeah
the more like me being an ass and I
admit it but something something we both
have I think experience is when we
review something that's popular at the
time but but we don't like you know or
when we do something that we think is
going to be good that maybe doesn't it
doesn't have the same reaction we expect
but over time people come back to it why
do you think that happens and what do
you think happens in that bit of time
you mean like you do a review and people
don't like it but over time they go back
and they're like you're right yeah or
they'll quote it or they'll really
doraville even demand more um well
what's what's funny and people may not
believe this at first but when I started
doing reviews I started doing like
written movie reviews for a comic book
called nights at the dinner table
and I'm going to go back to Star Wars on
this IFRIC my first written review was
about the Phantom Menace and I hate it
and I slagged it just destroyed it now
for context when did this come out I
noticed immediately immediately after
the Phantom Menace came out yes right at
the time we premiered like the day after
and I destroyed it and I got so much
hate mail so much they couldn't believe
it they're like how dare you how dare
you
this movie is fantastic because and
people may not remember this when the
Phantom Menace first came out everyone
everyone loved it it was critically
praised I remember that and yeah critics
critics widespread almost universally
loved that movie Roger Ebert I forgot
the rating was it was almost like 3 and
1/2 step see a three and a half or four
yeah it was up there
it was beloved fans loved it critics
loved it everyone loved this movie I
hated
I almost walked out of the theater when
I don't smoke out of that deer it was
like three minutes before the end I
couldn't stand it I couldn't stand I
would I wrote a review I hated it
hate mail universally and that's when
the guy actually hired me on because it
was the Howard Stern thought I was like
I'm so sorry I had people hate this
review I'll stop writing I said he's
like are you kidding me people aren't
like subscribing like crazy because they
hate so much and I'm like okay but yeah
I'm so but the thing is I was right
nowadays people hate that movie they
hate it but you wouldn't know that at
the time because it was like a delirium
effect people walked out of that movie
they could it was unconscionable at the
time the inconceivable that there could
be a bad Star Wars movie in fact if at
the time when Return of the Jedi was the
only splash star was movie and I had
told you there will be another Star Wars
movie and it will be bad that would be
madness man you just know that's
impossible but here we are you know and
I think people walked out of that
theater delirious just that fight scene
was awesome dude it was the one thing I
liked in that movie that is the heart
there that maybe cuz it ended on that
note I know
yeah they latched on to that scene to do
because they're like that music you
could do anything to that music and
they'd be awesome dude dude look at it
you know you could order a sandwich -
did this - why did you block it you can
do you know Jerry Gus position movie
would be amazing with that view even
they just had on a list epic you know
walking through the desert and it took
months it took months it took till it
reached home video and they watch it at
home and they just what oh my god this
is terrible
but they turned around and I was right
you know
that was smug that I told him I was
right that was like you know I hate to
be that guy who said you know what I
don't yeah I like me but yeah that was
one of the major things um I don't know
if I've reviewed a movie on the show
that was like I've had people turn
around on like Final Fantasy but that
wasn't my goal
I wasn't like even though I said it's
like I'm gonna prove you wrong on Final
Fantasy that wasn't like I was just kind
of breaking balls you know but don't
know if I've ever like maybe V logs here
and there I was talking like new Robo
Cop or spider-man but like I don't know
if I've ever done a most that most of
the movies that I've reviewed have been
like pretty much universally bad or but
we're like or like I've shown people
movies like red-brown movies that I've
been like these are terrible movies but
you should see him you know people like
them but I don't know what about you
like you probably what movies have
haven't you turned around and have
people turned around for you like uh boy
it's is not as much movies as much as um
events this stuff like that the battle
with the nerd my first archive
everyone's like you can't do that you
can't possibly do that well uh you know
and like even the anniversaries and yet
people are always asking for more as
well
well people thought that so many people
thought the feud with the nerd was
serious this is well even outside of
that though uh like when we did the big
final battle stuff you're like yeah you
might want to wrap this up I think we're
kind of done or whatever but then like
it's not one number one questions I ever
get are you gonna do more with the nerdy
gonna have an hour battle you gonna
bring that back
so yeah it's always one of those things
where it's like you know you just serve
I always play to my gut just like even
if I know I'm gonna do science can give
a lot of people disagree mana steals in
our great example no but everyone said
don't review it uh and that's like the
most refute that's the most viewed
review I've ever done you and I got so
much heat for that review I think
everybody who disliked it did I think
that um that was amazing yeah I think
the only one I got that much bagpipes
affright Dark Knight Rises like both my
Brad was talking to lay out bread Joe
let's even say you don't thank God you
said that because like everyone
coming to me for a while than you defuse
the fan Linkara pussy i think i know
you're going with this right he waited a
month to review Man of Steel we took the
firestorm on that one he's like well why
does everybody and nobody came to me
angry I don't get ya cuz they okay the
odds all because I said I didn't like
that movie and nobody came nobody cared
I said it was like yeah because they all
freaking torched us on him they were
tired yeah every once awhile as Rob says
every once awhile on its Facebook we
just wants to get a little rise just or
play puppet master oh just say something
bad about Man of Steel yeah just be like
taps fuck its dancers I've gotta say
wait what Dark Knight Rises I'll just
just to give a little bit of a ride he
said no pun intended I do it with the
Pacific Rim which I said was okay and
they're like oh look it's the best move
for you ever anyway I just did it again
so they're gonna see this video if you
like all the comments no it's just gonna
be people saying why man to steal during
a Verizon Pacific race should this even
though we like Pacific Rim then I was
wrong about the heads on this video are
gonna be amazing it's just gonna be like
a flame or dad's puppets that we just
brought the three movies the Visayan
gonna be about anything we talked about
it's just gonna be those brilliant
suiting the crossover movies was an
arduous but I wouldn't have traded it
for the world
kickass Casey we I've never run that
much in play over more difficult right
but I'm not gonna play that was amazing
I don't want the only people not to walk
away from that injury if I don't know
any of the places you would have thought
I would have been crippled it would have
been kick ass